there are new concerns this morning
about air quality after a massive fire
at a chemical plant in Texas Janet
shamlian is in Deer Park outside Houston
where authorities issued a
shelter-in-place warning Janet good
morning good morning and this happened
just within the last couple of hours we
are four miles from the plant just
outside of the zone where officials say
they have determined what they are
calling an actionable amount of benzene
at this point there is a shelter in
place order for all of Deer Park
authorities are saying that people
should stay in their homes at this time
they say the residential areas are not
currently impacted but the stem L may be
noticeable we sure can smell it where we
are here the Deer Park High School is
just a couple of miles from that plant
again Deer Park schools have shut down
as well as five other school districts
yesterday there was a brief flare-up at
the plant that was quickly put out
within about an hour but again those big
black flames could be seen all the way
from downtown Houston benzene is a known
carcinogen according to the CDC people
who breathe in high levels of it may
experience drowsiness headaches and
dizziness
it is likely at this hour David a lot of
people have not heard of this very early
here people are being asked to shelter
in place we can hear the sirens behind
you Jenna thank you very much